there's a great example of the RAF which
is the Royal Air Force one of their
former pilots was retrained at taxpayers
expense as a stripper which i think is
very good usage taxpayers really hello
I'm Jun araga with reason TV and I'm
here with Matthew Elliott from the UK
taxpayers alliance UK taxpayers alliance
how long has it been running you're the
founder what was the impetus to start
this taxpayers less would be going now
for six years so the impetus was really
the government has started massively
hiking spending in the UK and literally
spending on education healthcare as
doubled in real terms over the past ten
years and the trouble was all this extra
spending was coming in without any real
checks on how the money was being spent
so taxpayers needed a representative
group to actually look at how the money
was being spent and point out where as
we've been wasted I think that taxpayers
across the world have reacted to the
financial crisis and have actually
wanted to improve their lot and make
sure their money's been well spent and
whole portage to account but it's
happened differently in different
countries obviously the Tea Party
movement in the u.s. if the UK we've had
the rise of my group to taxpayers
alliance but also the big reaction
against the MPs expenses scandal last
year and who's found their abusing a lot
of their expenses and if you go to
Germany there's a huge reaction last
year when it's taught the talk of a
Greek bailout of the Greek economy
following their crisis with the bond
markets and there's huge reaction there
big rising yours gets in so this
taxpayer rebellion has happened in a
different way in different countries
according to the cultural temperament
partly of the people but it is a fun
phenomena that's going on worldwide what
have been the most surprising
discoveries that TPA has made since
starting to dig into government and
expenditure I we did everything right
from the top end they're looking
business development grants something
called the regional development agencies
which basically sucked out a lot of
taxpayers cash from small firms actually
did nothing to actually help them really
we expose that and thankfully they're
now being shut down by the new
government we also also exposed slightly
more sort of comical things to see a
funny story with us there's a great
example of the RAF which is the Royal
Air Force one of their former pilots was
retrained at taxpayers expense as a
stripper which i think is very good
usage taxpayers really what's the main
strategy you've employed throughout in
building the organization I think the
key point was a ruthless focus on the
mainstream media so trying to get lots
of broadcasting hits and lots of
newspaper hits and now we roughly get
about six to seven hundred mainstream
media hits every month so the public are
very aware of what the taxpayers lights
are doing and as a result of that the
politicians are very aware of what we're
doing in there for you know they're
being watched by the TPA and by a sixty
thousand supporters so really working on
a mainstream media coverage and that
meant producing very newsworthy report
so would make a good copy for newspaper
editors and I hope made politicians feel
they really be watched and they're all
made them more accountable how does the
relationship between the UK and the EU
make your work complex the EU is much
less transparent than the UK so we have
less rights as taxpayers and the
citizens to actually request details at
home and he's been spent over the in the
EU and that's one of things are trying
to work on at the moment you're
approximately 10 billion pounds around
money from the UK ghost the EU each year
but we have no oversight on that but i
think is a crucial area and because the
EU because Brussels is so far removed
from the people there is a general
feeling out there they're less
accountable and sometimes you hear about
Jim more waste going on and the fact for
example they're asking for a six percent
rise in their budget this year when all
the national governments within the EU
are actually cutting back on spending
you have said a lot about their I would
say their arrogance when it comes to tax
base rights what are the key takeaways
your work I think the key thing is
within build you of the organization
people won't necessarily join the group
as the Taxpayers Alliance but there
could be a specific issue a specific
aspect of government waste or specific
tax they're particularly concerned about
which you can then use to actually set
up a Facebook group or set up a Twitter
feed on it and I should get people
engaged in that way great recovery
finally what you're most proud of I'd
say I'm most proud of our work on
transparency because I believe that
whether or not you want high government
spending or local government spending
taxpayers have a right to know how their
money's been sent here for many of them
it's up to forty percent fifty percent
of their income it's a lot of money and
they have rights too so I think through
our work on the Freedom of Information
Act through our work and actually
encouraging the new government to bring
in its own transparency measures and put
different receipts online or what have
you we've actually own taxpayers a great
service and what it means is going
forward every taxpayer every taxpayer in
the country can go to their home
computer and they can be the the army of
armchair accountants if you like
actually holding government to account
and making sure their money's well spent
thank you for joining us Matthew for
reason TV this is june aeronca
you